donc pour vous finalement ça change pas
grand chose grâce à la vente à emporter
ça change ça change fondamentalement
quand même malheureusement le temps mené
par rendez vous je suis surpris qu'ils
aient pas plus de monde en terrasse mais
oui ça un début d'une façon il faut être
prudent et on verra dans les mois qui
viennent ce qu'il va se passer mais
profitons du moment présent et on verra
on verra plus tard
et vous êtes vous êtes donc vous aussi
un habitué de ce café non pas du tout
parce que moi je ne suis pas parisien et
c'est vrai que j'apprécie ce moment kiki
pour moi me manquer et de retrouver la
convier convivialité autour d'un café
certes ça fait plaisir ça vous aimez ça
vous avez manqué ça m'avait beaucoup
manqué moi pour ma part mais ea vous
avez prévu de faire d'autres choses
aujourd'hui
théâtre cinéma
mu est surtout prévu de travailler et
éventuellement des jeux en terrasse si
on arrive à trouver une place ce midi
merci beaucoup monsieur bonne matinée
bon café voilà donc les premiers clients
vont commencer à arriver ils ne sont pas
encore très nombreux ici sur les
terrasses parisiennes
mais les restos les restaurateurs sont
optimistes et espèrent une belle journée
pour cette réouverture
merci merci marie amélie qui est dans
les rues de paris
je disais avec renan l'aise blaise on va
vous retrouver tout à l'heure peut-être
à d'autres endroits vous aller sillonner
un petit peu le le quartier pour nous
présenter un peu toutes ces réouvertures
de commerce de terrasses etc
à tout à l'heure je me tourne vers vous
elsa ou est ce qu'on peut faire un point
justement sur ces histoires de jauge lui
le patron du lafitte en a un petit peu
parlé est-ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer comment ça va se passer
concrètement sur les terrasses à quel
pourcentage d'occupation alors ça a été
très détaillé et le gouvernement est
revenu à plusieurs reprises sur le
protocole qui a été mis en place pour
les restaurants et les terrasses dans ce
qui se passe à partir d'aujourd'hui
c'est que les terrasses sont ouvertes
mais avec une jauge de 50%
on peut venir à 6 personnes maximum par
table et les salles intérieures sont
fermés le réouvriront que le 9 juin donc
seconde étape du déconfinement cette
fois ci les terrasses seront à 100% et
les salles ouvertes à 50% et le 30 juin
quand même parce que on espère reprendre
un petit peu une vie normale ces
prochains jours il y aura une levée de
ces jauges là et puis surtout ce sera
accompagnée avec la levée finale du
couvre-feu qui était à 23 heures le 9
juin qui sera décalée qui n'existera
plus en fait à partir du 30 juin
est ce que vous savez si des terrains
des restaurants restent fermés et
attendre justement la réouverture des
salles le 9 juin
bah c'est toute la question avec les
restaurants parce que certains ne
disposent pas de terrasse donc pour une
bonne partie des restaurants la vraie
ouverture ne sera pas aujourd'hui mais
le 9 juin certains restaurants se sont
débrouillés à leur manière pour
installer on l'a vu dans
rue de paris notamment dans de grandes
villes françaises des terrasses sur la
chaussée mais sa nécessité quand même
enfin une certaine forme de débrouille
sachant que c'est quand même des restos
qui tiennent voilà on l'a dit depuis 200
jours donc c'était quand même un petit
peu compliqué pour eux on a des
restaurants emblématique qui indique ne
pas rouvrir aujourd'hui par exemple
restaurant de philippe etchebest à paris
qui indiquait nous rouvrir que le 9 juin
parce que dans les circonstances
actuelles c'est pas intéressant
économiquement parlant pour eux de
rouvrir est ce que ces restaurants
bénéficieront toujours des aides du coup
jusqu'au 9 juin comment ça va se passer
est-ce que vous avez des informations
sur les aides est ce qu'elles vont être
prolongées même au delà des réouvertures
ou des cons a rouvert en coupe les aides
il est question actuellement en fait ces
établissements dont ont bénéficié d'
aide depuis le 29 octobre et pendant le
premier confinement également là il est
question de lever progressivement ces
aides alors ça va se faire par paliers
ça va se faire en fonction des
différents seuils de déconfinement les
ânes ne vont pas être levé à partir
d'aujourd'hui ce serait plutôt à partir
de mi juin voire fin juin que là on va
pouvoir commencer à avoir des
restaurants se débrouiller avec leurs
propres chiffres d'affaires leur propre
clientèle et sans aux aides du
gouvernement
et est ce que tous les restaurants vont
rouvrir justement est-ce qu'il ya pas
certains restaurants qui resteront
fermés justement parce qu'ils n'auront
pas réussi à surmonter cette crise je
n'ai pas les chiffres sur le nombre la
proportion de restaurants qui ont fermé
je sais qu'un mois était prévu qu'un
restaurant sur trois mettre la clé sous
la porte notamment les restaurants qui
n'ont pas pu passer à la vente à
emporter parce que cette vente à
emporter se prête bien pour des
restaurants qui font des plats un petit
peu particulier des sushis des pizzas
etc
mais beaucoup moins pour les brasseries
parisiennes qui font des plats peut-être
un peu plus onéreux est beaucoup plus
difficile à transporter donc on va voir
fin juin et à partir du 30 juin quels
établissements auront tenu et la
proportion d'établissements qui ont
finalement mis la clé sous la porte
malheureusement alors la tortue bleue 78
nous a rejoints sur le chat de youtube
bonjour la tortue bleue qui nous dit où
est ce que ça a été question pour nous
de les questions pratiques sur les
cinémas les jauges
dans les théâtres etc qu'est ce qu'il
reste fermé qu'est ce qui est toujours
interdite ce 19 mai ou si vous n'avez
pas de questions dites nous tout
simplement qu'est ce que vous comptez
faire aujourd'hui pour cette nouvelle
phase de déconfinement est ce que vous
avez envie d'aller en terrasse ou est-ce
que vous préférez réservez votre
prochain concert parce que effectivement
les salles de spectacle vous pouvoir ré
ouvrir l as que vous avez des
informations justement est ce qu'il sera
possible d'aller en concert ce week end
alors il ne sera pas possible d'aller au
concert dès ce week-end en revanche est
un concert test qui va avoir lieu le 29
mai l'accord hôtel à l'aréna de mercy ce
sera indochine qui va justement donner
ce concert donc le problème actuellement
c'est que ça va être une expérimentation
qui requiert la présence de près de 7000
personnes
et pour le moment près de 5000 personnes
manquent à l'appel
en tout cas quoi qu'il arrive cette
expérimentation va permettre de
déterminer dans quelle mesure les
contaminations sont plausibles dans ce
type d'événement voix c'est plus pour
voir si les protocoles sanitaires en
salles de concerts vont tenir la route
mais ce qu'on sait d'ores et déjà c'est
qu'il faudra à priori pour tous les
rassemblements de plus de 1000 personnes
qui peuvent impliquer des concerts
présentés en pas sanitaires comme quoi
on a été vaccinée donc de doses on a un
certificat de vaccination au bout de ces
deux doses là comme quoi on vient de
réaliser un test pcr négatif sous 72
heures ou comme quoi on dispose
également d'un certificat d'immunité à
savoir le fait d'avoir été malade du coc
vide dans les derniers jours qui prouve
qu'on a encore des anticorps et que donc
on va pas transmettre la maladie
merci elle n'a alors que vous voyez
juste derrière nous des images en direct
sur le vieux port de marseille des
images qui sont tournés par l' agence
france-presse
alors quelqu'un dans le chat du
figaro.fr justement olivier 111 nous
nous dit mort de rire il ya plus de
journalistes en terrasse que je clients
la preuve que non marseille en fait
c'est peut-être juste une question de
temps évidemment à paris fait un petit
peu gris fait un petit peu moche alors
qu'on voit bien que dans le sud
il ya de nombreuses personnes en
terrasse justement j'ai une question en
regardant ces images à elsa ces
personnes ses clients n'ont pas de
masque est ce qu'on peut faire un point
sur le port du masque sur les terrasses
dans les restaurants à partir
d'aujourd'hui
alors il ya un protocole vous faites
bien te poser la question parce qu'un
protocole très détaillée par rapport au
port du masque donc le protocole
actuellement en vigueur veut qu'on porte
le masque dans tous les moments en fait
où on n'est pas en train de consommer un
plat ou une boisson donc pendant la
commande au moment du paiement et
éventuellement si on se rend dans la
salle intérieur du restaurant pour aller
aux toilettes il y avait la question de
savoir si c'était autorisé ou non on
arrive quand même à des niveaux de
détails assez apprécié ce sera autorisée
malgré ce qui avait été dit au départ
donc voilà pour le port du masque
on a tous ces éléments là et sinon
autres éléments à savoir également à qui
fait partie du protocole il sera
simplement autorisé de consommer assise
et non debout ce qui est interdit
donc là on voit bien qu'il ya quelqu'un
qui est parti juste derrière sur les
images en direct de la fp donc ils ont
bien remis leur masse qu'ils ont bien
appliqué les règles
est ce que on peut imaginer des des
sanctions en fait comment comment c'est
possible de sanctionner vous vous venez
de détailler le protocole en vigueur
donc sur ce port du masque c'est un
petit peu lunaire j'ose dire comment
c'est possible de contrôler et de
veiller à ce qu'on a bien mirent en est
en fait de maître pour aller aux
toilettes est ce que c'est pas des
règles qui seront qui seront voit être
pas respecté comment oui alors
évidemment ça un protocole incitatif
c'est le protocole qui devrait être
respectée
si on veut vraiment que les gestes
barrières soient respectés également
après c'est vrai qu'il n'y aura pas de
sanctions prévues dans ces
établissements si jamais on ne porte pas
le mas correctement en revanche il ya
quelque chose qui est quand même assez
bon à savoir c'est que ces dernières
semaines la vente à emporter d'alcool a
été interdite sur la voie publique donc
par les bars mais cette fois ci pour
consommer par exemple il y avait
certaines images sur le canal
saint-martin et c'est pour éviter les
rassemblements et donc encore une fois
les contaminations et là les amendes et
les sanctions qui était prévu à l'époque
sont prolongées c'est à dire que si on
est pris en train de consommer une pinte
à l'extérieur et sur la voie publique
la halle amende de 135 euros quand même
qui était prévu vaut toujours
aujourd'hui et pour les prochains jours
très bien n'hésitez pas à nous contacter
à nous a parlé avec
le tchad je vous vois je vous lis sur le
chat de la page youtube du figaro
d'ailleurs je vois une question de
vincent le noble en sait-on plus sur la
réouverture des discothèques est là vous
en avait parlé en préambule
elles sont fermées depuis plus d'un an
maintenant est ce que est ce qu'elles
ont des perspectives d'avenir
alors ce sont justement des
établissements qui se plaignent en ce
moment de ne pas avoir d' horizons de
réouverture ce sont les seuls
établissements réalité à ne pas en avoir
il compare souvent leur cas avec celui
des saunas ou des clubs libertins qui
eux ont un horizon l'île de ré ouverture
alors que les boîtes non globalement ce
qui est estimé à l'heure actuelle c'est
qu'une boîte
une des boîtes de nuit sur quatre
pourrait mettre la clé sous la porte
à la fin de la crise pourrait ne pas
rouvrir une fois à la pandémie est
terminée il n'y a pas nécessairement
d'horizon de réouverture seule une date
a été évoquée par le gouvernement et le
cabinet d'alain griset donc ils
dépendent du ministère de l'économie
ce secteur sera fixée le 15 juin au plus
tard sur une éventuelle date de
réouverture qui lie pas encore certaine
donc cet été on pourra pas danser dans
les clubs
si l'oeuf s'il se fixe ils sont fixés à
mi juin est ce que ce serait possible
d'envisager une ouverture à mi juillet
ce serait possible mais c'est pas encore
sûr du tout et il ya tout un paradoxe en
réalité dans cette situation parce que
des bars vont être amenées finalement à
se prêter un petit peu a joué le jeu de
discothèque a débarqué diffuser la
musique des restaurants également et le
secteur des discothèques ont par son
sort avec celui de ces établissements là
et des plans et forme d'injustice
finalement dans le traitement qui est
fait entre ces différents établissements
alors d'après les dernières informations
qu'on a il ya quand même une nouvelle
piste qui a été mis sur la table celle
d'une soirée test qui pourrait survenir
à la manière des concertée ce dont on a
parlé tout à l'heure pour voir dans
quelle mesure ces lieux clos qui sont
quand même très propices aux
contaminations la vue en fonction des
différentes études qui sont parus
pourrait accueillir ou non du public
et s'il a accueilli du public ce serait
surreprésentation a priori mais là
encore on attend de nouvelles
informations sur présentation d'un pass
sanitaires à la manière de ce qu'on
disait pour les événements de plus de
1000 personnes
merci elsa n'hésitez pas à poser toutes
vos questions dans le tchat sur
lefigaro.fr
et sur le chat de youtube elsa et
moi-même essaierons d'y répondre en
direct
on va tout de suite rejoindre marie
amélie bauchet et renan laisse blaise
qui sont qui ont fait un petit peu de
chemin dans le 9e arrondissement de
paris qui sont toujours en direct et qui
sont dans un magasin je vois
marie-amélie marie amélie c'est à vous
ok alors brune nous sommes avec mathieu
le patron de dit bonjour à la dame qui
est un atelier boutique c'est ça et qui
est fermé depuis le 19 mars par mathieu
dans quel état d'esprit vous êtes
aujourd'hui pour ce grand jour après m
presque deux mois de fermeture de mois
pile assez surexcités je dois vous le
dire on est super content de refaire je
suis content de rouvrir
tout est prêt je suis ravi la boutique
est prête j'étais un article nouveau je
suis ravi très très heureux et elle vous
avez prévu des choses un peu
particulière pour ce grand jour quand
même pourvu du coup ouais j'ai prévu un
truc parce que comme on n'a pas parlé de
culture pendant presque un an maintenant
et que j'expose souvent des artistes
là j'ai fait une expo collective donc il
ya neuf artistes que j'ai accroché hier
et donc c'est un une belle expo avec
plein de taille à des tableaux il ya des
dessins il ya des broderies à des choses
assez différentes des artistes que j'ai
l'habitude d'exposer des petits nouveaux
que j'ai été dénichée sur instagram et
est ce qui fait que tu es vraiment
content c'est une belle expo et j'invite
évidemment tout le monde à venir y jeter
un oeil
d'accord donc c'est pour mettre un peu
en valeur ces artistes leur donner aussi
une place et vous pensez faire venir des
gens grâce à ça et c'est peu dire oui je
pense parce que j'ai fait un peu de pub
sur les réseaux sociaux qui sont quand
même un super outil pour nous dans
l'image et puis voilà j'ai des bons
retours
donc je pense que de pas mal de gens
vont venir voir d'accord très bien et
donc là aujourd'hui vous pouvez l'ouvrir
mais quand même des certaines
contraintes loisirs samokov way
absolument on respecte tous donc il ya
huit mètres carrés pour ne pas une
personne paru m² donc là moi j'ai quatre
personnes maximum je suis en train de
gepam il affiche encore mais je suis pas
ouvert ouvert encore donc ça va j'ai mes
panneaux derrière la caisse les gels
hydroalcooliques y en a trois dans toute
la boutique
voilà et puis les toutes les autres et
ouverture ça s'est bien passé aussi donc
je suis très serein près complètement
serein et super super tente vraiment
content en fait et et vous comptez un
peu écoulée vostok
alors oui j'ai effectivement pas mal de
stock mais j'ai fait venir encore pas
mal de choses pendant le confinement ce
n'était pas évident d'avoir des
livraisons pendant la boutique ouverte
donc enfin les jongler avec la maison et
les livraisons et mais j'ai plein de
nouveautés aussi d'un suis bien et puis
je fais beaucoup les brocantes donc que
j'ai eu tant de d'aller chercher à
droite à gauche des petites choses
toujours sur internet donc il ya des
choses bien est ce que vous comptez un
peu élargir vos horaires d'ouverture
pour permettre aux gens de venir plus
longtemps après le travail à la pause
déjeuner so lu ment alors déjà je suis
toujours ouvert en général de 11h à 20h
déjà là aujourd'hui je veux mourir
jusqu'à 21h parce que ça fait du bien et
je pense tout là-haut - elle est la
preuve les deux premières semaines
jusqu'à 21h peut-être tous les jours je
vais voir mes gars nous oui
élargissement des horaires d'ouverture
beaucoup beaucoup moins et optimiste a
du coup pour cette période qui sont ces
races ouais il faut il d'abord il faut
être optimiste
et puis oui bien sûr oui il va se passer
des choses super on est content merci
mathieu avec plaisir merci et vous voilà
les les commerçants sont optimistes dans
l'ensemble est très très heureux de les
ouvrir aujourd'hui et la plupart
attendent du monde pour cette
réouverture
merci merci marie amélie on vous
retrouve tout à l'heure quand vous aurez
trouvé un autre commerce qui vous
ouvrira ses portes
merci de nous suivre toujours sur
lefigaro.fr et sur la page youtube du
figaro on vous fait vivre cette nouvelle
phase de déconfinement en direct posez
nous toutes vos questions pratiques
on essaiera d'y répondre j'ai une
question c'est pas vraiment une question
mais une remarque de claude therrien sur
le le chat
de youtube qui me dit c'est bien ce
déconfinement à petite dose prudence
toujours ce qui me tend une perche
elsa à quel moment le gouvernement peut
dire stop on arrête tout ce qu'ils ont
fixé des critères alors le gouvernement
part du principe que les différents
seuils qui ont été fixés les différents
paliers de déconfinement vont servir à
une reprise progressive et sécurisé
qu'il n'y aura pas à refermer
a priori les établissements on a quand
même olivier ferrand qui s'est tout
récemment exprimé sur le sujet en
indiquant que d'après ce qui avait été
fait d'après les mesures qui ont été
mises en place pour le moins n'était pas
question de fermer en tout cas tout
serait fait pour éviter tout ça en
revanche un seuil a été fixé un taux
d'incidence de 400 donc de 400 cas sur
cent mille contamination qui seraient
pris en compte pour éventuellement
refermée mais cette fois ci au cas par
cas et pas sur le territoire sur
l'ensemble du territoire national
les établissements seraient plutôt ciblé
par département éventuellement ce seuil
était 250 auparavant il a été réhaussée
parce qu'on prend désormais en compte la
campagne de vaccination qui progresse et
qui justement s'est adressé aux
personnes les plus fragiles qui sont
désormais pour une bonne partie d'entre
elles immunisés merci elsa on a vu sur
les images à l'instant de renan laisse
blaise qui est avec maria amelie
embauchés sur le terrain que ce
commerçant avait mis en place une petite
exposition pour attirer on va dire les
clients lors de ce déconfinement on peut
parler notamment de tous les autres
lieux culturels qui rouvre aujourd'hui
les musées les bibliothèques l on peut
faire un poids / / / / les jauges par
exemple dans les musées ou verizon tél
alors là aussi le gouvernement était
très précis sur le sujet donc là on
parlait d'une jauge d'une personne par
huit mètres carrés donc le globalement
dans un petit établissement ça fait à
peu près trois personnes qui peuvent
rentrer et fréquenté cet établissement
cette jauge était d'une personne par 10
mètres carrés l'an dernier lors du
premier des confinement donc ça a été un
petit peu resserré en revanche à partir
du 9 juin cette jauge va changer est
passé à une personne par 4 mètres carrés
pour être levé à partir du 30 juin
donc là on pourra se rendre à partir de
cette date là du 30 juin dans une
exposition dans une galerie d'art dans
des bibliothèques librement a priori et
son juge imposer toujours avec le masque
alors évidemment toujours avec le masque
le port du masque
et encore obligatoire dans les lieux
clos donc il n'y a pas vraiment de
changement en réalité sur le sujet mais
pas non plus de sanctions prévues comme
on l'indiqué tout à l'heure alors après
par contre ce qui était intéressant dans
le témoignage que rien à voir c'est
l'idée de réouverture et d'élargissement
du justement des horaires d'ouverture
des établissements
ça vaut aussi pour les cinémas qui se
sont vraiment adapté à ces horaires là
sachant que la plupart des gens se
rendent éventuellement au cinéma dans la
soirée ce qui est peu compatible avec
les couvre-feux donc à partir de cette
semaine on a vu certains cinémas
notamment des mk2 proposer des séances
dès 8h30 du matin voire dès 6h30 du
matin pour certains films qu'il souhaite
mettre en valeur alors certains pour une
offre un petit peu particulière offre
des viennoiseries pour les personnes qui
voudraient se rendre à ces séances très
très matinal et il s'adapte également
concernant les horaires de soirée donc
le dernier film vraisemblablement la
journée sera diffusée vers 19 heures
pour être compatible avec le couvre-feu
et contrairement à ce qu'on pouvait
imaginer les billets de cinéma et c'est
bon à savoir quand même ne seront pas
horodatées donc ne pourront pas faire
office de preuve pour se déplacer
pendant le couvre-feu
c'est encore une modalité à connaître
parce qu'on pourrait penser que qu'on
pourrait échapper au couvre-feu de cette
manière là mais pas encore en tout cas
pas céder à ces prochains jours avant le
30 euros au 30 juin il faudra rentrer
encore chez soi avant 21h donc on essaie
de tenir jusqu'à cette date là on aura
toujours des attestations du coup à
fournir voilà de nouvelles attestations
déjà été mise en ligne aujourd'hui qui
se prête au couvre-feu de 21h
contre 19 heures hier il y en aura
également deux nouvelles pour le
couvre-feu de 23h à partir du 9 juin et
les motifs de déplacement pendant
couvre-feu les motifs impérieux restent
toujours les mêmes globalement où est-ce
qu'ils ont changé au les motifs restent
toujours les mêmes
très bien je rebondis sur ce que vous
disiez sur les cinémas j'ai une question
peut-être un petit peu
naïve mais est ce qu'on pourra manger du
pop-corn on sale enfin où est-ce qu'on
doit garder le masque comment ça se
passe c'est pas une question naïve du
tout sachant qu' il y réussit quelque
chose qui est prévu dans le protocole à
ce sujet là ce sera interdit de
consommer du pop corn des friandises des
boissons pendant une séance l'idée étant
de garder son mas tout le monde la
séance toujours pour limiter les
contaminations en revanche c'est une
subtilité à connaître c'est que c'est
une règle temporaire qui a priori ne
vaudra plus à partir du 9 juin
donc à partir de là on pourra re
consommer à nouveau en salle sachant que
ça constitue aussi une bonne partie pas
l'essentiel mais une bonne partie des
revenus des cinémas qui ont été fermés
pendant si longtemps
merci merci à vous de nous suivre dans
le chat de nous suivre sur la page
youtube du figaro encore une fois et sur
lefigaro.fr pour ce grand jour le 19 mai
2021 la réouverture de tous les lieux de
loisirs pratiquement et principalement
des terrasses qui sont fermés depuis
plus de 200 jours comme disait elsa au
début de ce direct ça dès la salle g
nous pose une question sur youtube c'est
pas vraiment une question encore une
fois mais il soulève une vraie question
en tout cas
en dix ans les commerces souffrent
depuis plus d'un an il faut trouver des
solutions efficaces au lieu de refermer
dans le futur elsa est ce qu'il est
prévu encore une fois de faire du stop
and go comme on a comme on a vu pendant
quasiment un an maintenant parce qu'on a
indiqué tout à l'heure le but est
d'éviter d'avoir à fermer à nouveau ces
établissements alors évidemment si le
nombre d'entrants en réanimation remonte
si le taux d'incidence remonte fortement
si on a des signes comme ça qui indique
une recrudescence de l'épidémie il
faudra fermer au cas par cas mais le
gouvernement part du principe que dans
l'état actuel des choses il n'y aura pas
à procéder à une telle fermeture à
nouveau des commerces qui pourrait être
fatal pour les commerces les restaurants
tous les établissements qui sont fermés
depuis si longtemps alors on voit les
images en direct
derrière moi qu'ils sont des images de
paris si je si je me trompe ou peut-être
toujours
2 2 marseille j'ai pas j'ai pas cette
information à vous dire je pense que
c'est à paris c'est bien paris on
retient que c'est bien paraît donc il ya
quand même pas mal de monde qui commence
à s'installer en terrasse sans masque
qui discutent le petit café peut-être
avant de démarrer la journée et le
travail gg j'ai un commentaire encore
une fois une personne sur le chat du
figaro.fr cette fois ci le route us ou
qui qui nous demandent en fait de mettre
en ligne le nombre de places disponibles
dans les hôpitaux
effectivement pour pouvoir voir si ce
déconfinement était une bonne chose
aujourd'hui alors je n'ai pas les
chiffres à vous fournir aujourd'hui mais
en revanche on peut vous redire encore
une fois que si jamais le taux
d'incidence dépasse les 400 pour cent
mille habitants
il y aurait des mesures de fermeture qui
serait plutôt territorialisée et exor
fermé tout le pays comme comme elsa a
dit précédemment je n'hésitais pas à
poser d'autres questions sur d'autres
d'autres réouverture il n'y a pas que
les terrasses même si c'est très
symbolique et c'est sur les images en
direct qu'on vous montre sur sur le
figaro il ya aussi d'autres d'autre
chose qui change aujourd'hui notamment
pour les rassemblements familiaux ou les
mariages pour toute la filière
événementielle en fait qui qui retrouve
un peu de couleurs aujourd'hui non oui
alors déjà à partir d'aujourd'hui pour
commencer sur les mariages
il ya des restrictions qui sont levés
jusqu'à présent seules 6 personnes
pouvaient être présentes en mairie alors
ça dépend après des politiques des
mairies mais pour assister à un mariage
désormais ces étendues il me semble à 50
je ne suis pas certaine des 50 mais il
me semble que c'est bien ça en tout cas
il ya des dispositifs qui ont été
prévues et qui sont également très
précis pour les mariages donc une fois
la cérémonie lancer finalement le repas
lancé à une distanciation de deux sièges
entre invités à partir du 19 mai est
recommandée en quinconce donc là encore
très précis et à partir du 9 juin un
siège sur deux pourrait être occupé ces
restrictions seront levées à partir du
30 juin donc olivier ferrand l'indiqué
tout récemment
on part du principe que des mariages
pour situer se déroule dans des
conditions normales à partir de cette
date mais pas nécessairement avant les
conditions changent également pour des
événements qui sont bien moins heureux
à savoir les enterrements jusqu'à
présent seules 30 personnes pouvaient y
assister la jauge passe à 50 personnes à
partir du 19 mai puis à 75 à partir du 9
juin et là encore élevé à partir du 30
donc là aussi il ya des changements et
voilà sachant qu'au premier confinement
certaines de ces cérémonies avaient lieu
pour certains à distance ou d'enfin
voilà d'entendre la mesure de ce qui
était possible à l'époque
là on y voit un petit peu plus clair ce
sera probablement plus facile à
organiser
si je comprends bien du coup pour tous
ceux qui ont qui avait annulé déjà
l'année dernière leur mariage ou le
baptême de leur enfant etc
vaut mieux décaler plutôt à juillet août
ou là on a un peu tout les voit partir
du 30 juin on est presque certain de
pouvoir assister à un mariage organisé
un mariage dans des conditions normales
sachant qu'il est aussi recommandé la
pratique des autotests s'est développée
voilà de se prêter à des tests pour être
sûr de ne pas contaminer les autres
invités ça peut se faire totalement dans
le respect des gestes barrières dont on
parle si souvent
finalement je vais merci merci d'être
avec nous de nous suivre en direct sur
lefigaro.fr et sur la page youtube du
figaro philippe dans le chat du
sur le figaro.fr dans le chat de notre
home pose une question d'ailleurs où
passent les piétons peut-être l'occasion
pour nous de rappeler qu'effectivement
la mairie de paris a autorisé les
terrasses d'éphémères à prolonger on va
dire ce dispositif qui savaient qu'ils
avaient mis en place l'année dernière
lors du déconfinement jusqu'à quand
s'est prolongée est ce que paris va
encore devenir une terrasse géantes
comme lors du déconfinement dernier
alors je n'ai pas nécessairement
d'informations à ce sujet là mais
vraisemblablement ses terrasses sont
voués à se prolonger pendant l'été le
temps de rééquilibrer un petit peu le
chiffre d'affaires qui était voilà qui
l'on a récupéré par rapport à leur
fermeture et notamment pour les
établissements qui n'avaient pas pu
comme on disait tout à l'heure passée à
la vente à emporter et c'est très
important pour eux de maintenir ses
terres à cela alors évidemment certains
se plaignent déplore justement voilà le
changement de paysage le fait de moins
pouvoir circuler dans les rues
parisiennes mais c'est quand même
dispositif qui sont voués à être
temporaire alors y avait certaines
images ce matin sur les réseaux sociaux
de terrasses qui avait été aménagée qui
n'était pas ouverte mais ferme et a
vraisemblablement ses terrasses voilà
gruge un petit peu et court circuite un
petit peu le protocole qui était prévu
au départ
mais il ya quand même un autre protocole
qui s'applique pour ses terrasses
fermées à savoir aéré de manière
systématique
voilà cette pièce là cet espace-là voir
mesurer le taux de co2 dans l'air ce qui
sera aussi le cas pour les entreprises
dont on peut parler également tout à
fait un peu importe au col on peut faire
un poids tout à fait pour peut-être pour
tous ces gens qui sont enterrés ce que
vous voyez en direct sur ces images de
paris d'une terrasse en part et qui est
totalement remplis quasiment
et peut-être qu'ils vont travailler
juste après ils se sont rendus donné
rendez vous juste avant de commencer le
travail peut-être d'embauché à 10 heures
est ce qu'on peut faire un point sur sur
l'entreprise et le télétravail est ce
que ça reste encore la norme aujourd'hui
le 19
elsa concernant de télétravail a pas de
changement de règle à l'heure actuelle
donc le fait de disposer globalement
d'entreprise et pour voilà ce qu'ils
peuvent télétravail est un pas ceux qui
ont besoin de se rendre sur le travail
le protocole qui vise à fixer un jour
sur place et quatre jours en télétravail
est encore de mise mais il va y avoir
des assouplissements à partir du 9 juin
et là ce seront aux entreprises au cas
par cas de réaliser des accords
d'entreprise pour voir et parfois avec
l'accord de leurs salariés de quelle
manière
organiser au mieux ce retour au travail
mais le télétravail en présentiel à 100%
et quand même exclu et globalement des
conseillers par le ministère la santé
pierre pierre loustaud sur le chat de
youtube nous fait une remarque il ya
bien trop de georges bien trop de jauge
par son administration s'est c'est
vraiment compliqué pour s'y retrouver
alors justement on est on est là pour
vous expliquer pour vous éclairer posez
nous toutes vos questions sur les jauges
dans l'est dans les salles de spectacles
dans les restos dans les musées dans les
théâtres dans les salles de cinéma
ella a compilé toutes ces informations
pour vous les journalistes service
économie du figaro elle essaye un peu de
répondre à toutes vos questions parce
que c'est vrai que c'est pas si c'est
pas très simple de s'y retrouver
est ce qu'on peut et est-ce que vous
avez des informations sur la
bibliothèque est ce que c'est considéré
comme comme un commerce est aussi une
personne par 4 mètres carrés où il s'est
encore une autre jauge supplémentaire
pour les hypothèques
alors à mon sens ça fait partie des
établissements non essentiels donc en
fait ce seront les mêmes règles qui
s'appliqueront une personne tous les 8
mètres carrés puis tous les quatre
mètres carrés à partir du 9 juin puis la
jauge sera levé à partir du 30
vraisemblablement c'est le cas pour les
bibliothèques
donc sachant qu'il ya un certain nombre
d'examens ce moment pour les étudiants
notamment les examens de médecine dès
aujourd'hui ce seront peut-être des
établissements aussi moins fréquenté ces
prochains jours alors sur la dernière
ligne droite il ya un domaine on va dire
un loisir parce que voilà aller au
cinéma ou en terrasse au théâtre à
l'opéra et c'est ce fait partie des
loisirs mais aussi à un autre loisir
c'est le sport le sport en salle et les
matchs les compétitions sportives et c
est ce qu on peut faire un point
là-dessus elsa s couche peux à partir
d'aujourd'hui elle est dans ma salle de
sport suivre un cours de zumba
non alors ça fait partie des
établissements qui ne rouvre pas
aujourd'hui les salles de sport du moins
pas pour les publics non prioritaires
donc ces établissements ces salles de
sport sont ouvertes pour les publics
prioritaires qui ont une maladie des
comorbidités qui donc ne doivent
s'entraîner pape afin de pratiquer une
activité sportive pour justement être en
bonne santé
ces établissements vont rouvrir à priori
à partir du 9 juin et avec dans les
mêmes conditions que ce qu'on a pu voir
l'an dernier à savoir avec des chemins à
suivre finalement dans la salle de sport
pour se rendre différentes machines du
gel hydroalcoolique
quand même par rapport au port du masque
cette fois ci ne sera pas obligatoire
car il se prête peu à l'activité
sportive ça paraît évident mais ce genre
de question peut se poser
alors après donc ça c'est pour pour les
salles de sport pour ceux qui
souhaiteraient pratiquer une activité
sportive en salle en revanche en
extérieur s'est autorisé un
vraisemblablement à partir d'aujourd'hui
les rassemblements les compétitions
sportives en extérieur sont autorisés
donc sur ce point là il n'ya pas
nécessairement grande chose à rajouter
concernant les compétitions sportives
notamment les matches les matchs de foot
la jauge d'accueil des spectateurs va
être fixée à 35 % dans un premier temps
avec un plafond de 1000 personnes
donc ce qui permet d'échapper aux pas
salutaire qui n'a pas encore était vrai
ce vraiment voter qui devrait l'être à
partir du 9 juin à partir du 9 juin les
sports avec contacts pourront reprendre
pour tous il a joué atteindra 65 % avec
un plafond de 5000 personnes globalement
on pourra aller au stade
mais voilà en étant un petit peu éloigné
des autres personnes qui assisteront à
un match il ya également quelque chose
qui a été précisé par rapport à l'euro
exactement
j'allais dire les compétitions sportives
qu'on attend tous cet été c'est le
roland-garros et le rock qu'est ce qui
sera possible de faire est qu'on pourra
aller voir des matchs de l'euro bat
l'euro se déroulera en partie à wembley
du 11 juin au 11 juillet donc pour ceux
qui souhaiteraient s'y rendre ibrahim en
tout cas en france des fans zone vont
être installés les juges n'ont pas
encore été définis mais il sera possible
de se rendre dans ces espaces là
probablement encore avec un pass
sanitaire s'il ya plus de 1000 personnes
qui s'y rendent
mais en tout cas les modalités doivent
encore être définis sur ce point là et
il ya également tout un panel de
critères pour les compétitions amateurs
mais l'âge invite les internautes à se
rendre sur les sites dédiés notamment du
ministère des sports pour pour en savoir
plus globalement dans un premier temps
les compétitions pourront pas compter
plus de 50 participants
merci elle va merci à vous tous qui nous
suivaient sur sur lefigaro.fr est sûre
et sur la page youtube du figaro on va
retrouver dans quelques instants
marie-amélie bauchet dès qu'elle sera
prêt elle est toujours dans les rues de
paris du 9e arrondissement
et je crois en train de de rencontrer
une créatrice de bijoux du 9e
arrondissement décalé dès qu'elle est
prête
on la prend tout de suite n'hésitez pas
à poser nos questions nous toutes vos
questions alors d'où ce france sur le
chat du figaro.fr nous dînons nous
n'attendons pas tous les compétitions
sportives et bah qu'est ce que vous
attendez alors est ce que vous préférez
aller au musée dans les bibliothèques ou
manger au restaurant en terrasse
qu'est ce qui vous fait plaisir qu'est
ce que vous avez envie de refaire qu'est
ce qui vous a manqué pendant toute cette
année de confinement stop and go et
c'est philippe qui lui a beaucoup de
commentaires toujours sur l'espace que
prend les rênes les terrasses danger
dans l'espace public
beaucoup de questions un petit peu
ironique un ce qu'ils risquent des
problèmes avec le tenancier s'ils
passent à travers la terrasse avec son
chien
non je ne pense pas sauf si votre chien
agressent des clients en terrasse
évidemment et apparemment il a déjà eu
une alerte altercation ce matin donc
effectivement je me souviens que lors du
déconfinement précédent les terrasses
avait été un gros sujets d'actualité
beaucoup de riverains notamment
s'étaient plaints du bruit du bruit fait
par les clients des terrasses de ses
terrasses prolonger effectivement des
terrasses éphémère qui colonise on va
dire l'espace public
nous allons retrouver je crois mariés
amélie qui est prête
marie amélie tu m'entends
aussi non on revient dans une boutique
elle aussi a fermé ses portes pendant
deux mois et qui s'apprête aujourd'hui à
réouvrir donc audrey bonjour vous êtes
la gérante de la boutique la divine y
est créatrice de bijoux
dans quel état d'esprit vous êtes
aujourd'hui après ces deux mois
ces deux longs mois de fermeture alors
on est hyper heureux de retrouver enfin
de pouvoir retrouver les clients parce
que c'est vrai que ce travail on le fait
pour partager partager avec les autres
sinon ça ne sert à rien donc voilà on
crée des bijoux donc il faut qu'ils
trouvent qu'ils trouvent leur leurs
propriétaires voilà donc on est très
heureux de pouvoir à nouveau ouvrir et
comment comment vous avez mis en place
le protocole ça une carte demandé par le
gouvernement dans votre boutique
alors c'est très simple on a regardé sur
le site du gouvernement les jauges déjà
pour voir combien de clients pouvaient
on pouvait accueillir normalement et on
peut en accueillir 3 donc ça fait un peu
moins que la dernière fois et puis voilà
on a racheté du gel on a
une table au centre pour faire une
petite circulation et voilà on a essayé
de faire un corner plus pour l'essayage
voilà on a mis les affiches pour dire
aux gens de ne pas trop toucher aux
bijoux parce que c'est essentiellement
ça le problème un petit peu voilà et
c'est pas trop contraignant pour vous ce
protocole
écoutez ça va on est maintenant habitué
on va dire ça on va dire qu'on est
habitués et que et les gens sont plutôt
sympathiques ils font attention il
respecte les jauges donc ça va et est ce
que vous comptez du coup élargir vos
horaires d'ouverture pour peut-être
écoulée vostok ou ce genre de mesures là
aussi pour vous aider on peut à
redémarrer votre activité
on va essayer on va essayer mais c'est
vrai que
on est enfin voilà on est deux et c'est
vrai qu'on est des mamans avec enfants
dont les emplois du temps sont pas
évidents à élargir non plus parce qu'on
y voit là mais on va essayer je vais
tout faire pour
pour pouvoir être la plus davantage
ouais ouais merci beaucoup et audrey
voilà bruno on s'adapte c'est un peu le
maître mot ici s'adapter trouver des
solutions pour continuer à accueillir
les clients tant des les meilleures
conditions possibles et il reprendre un
peu une vie un peu normal merci merci
merci marie amélie sur le chat du
figaro.fr d'où ce france donc a répondu
à ma question donc lui il ne suivra pas
les compétitions sportives c'est pas
vraiment ce qui lui a le plus manqué ce
qui lui a manqué c'est de manger au
resto ainsi que les soirées et bien
profitez-en bien en tout cas en terrasse
pour l'instant je bascule sur le chat de
youtube et pierre rousseau qui nous pose
une question sur les concerts justement
sur les soirées qui peuvent être
envisagées à partir d'aujourd'hui si le
concert test à paris n'est pas une
réussite c'est à dire que s'il ya des
contaminations au sein du public
est-ce que cela voudra dire qu'il n'ya
pas de concerts jusqu'à ce qu'on ait
atteint l'immunité collective alors déjà
est ce qu'on sait par rapport au
protocole qui va être déployé pendant
que ce concert c'est qu'il est très
stricte donc a priori va limiter au
maximum les risques de contamination
donc les gens qui vont y participer sont
sont tirés au sort
ils doivent présenter un premier test
négatif pcr à l'entrée puis passer par
la phase test antigénique et enfin dans
l'est dans les jours suivants le consul
de concerts transmettre les résultats
d'un autre test pcr pour évaluer le
nombre de contaminations
donc ça c'est ce qu'on sait sur le
protocole sachant que les masques vont
être également obligatoire pendant le
concert qu'il y aura aussi des caméras
de détection de port du masque qui vont
être déployés pour mesure à peu près la
proportion de gens qui le portent
correctement donc voilà on est dans un
cadre quand même très restrictif qui
limite au maximum les contaminations
c'est la plus grande expérimentation
menée à ce jour donc évidemment on va en
tirer des conclusions qui vont servir ou
non à la réouverture des salles de
concert mais donc là pour moment on peut
pas se prononcer
armand mais ce qu'on peut voir c'est que
à l'étranger des tests ont déjà été
faits dans des proportions un petit peu
similaires notamment en espagne
les contaminations d'un certain nombre
de contaminations n'ont pas été constaté
à la suite d'un concert qui a rassemblé
5000 personnes qui sont partis du
principe qu'il pouvait rouvrir ses
salles et également à liverpool de
soirée ont coup sur coup rassemblé 3000
personnes cette fois ci sans masquer des
personnes qui s'étaient présentés avec
un test pcr négatif et ils partent
désormais du principe à partir de ces
événements là qu'on pourra rouvrir les
salles de concert et les discothèques
sans risquer de relancer l'épidémie qui
encore une fois tout l'enjeu de ces
réouvertures merci elsa j'ai quelqu'un
dans le chat du figaro.fr qui est qui
qui donne un commentaire assez poétique
les couchers de soleil ça manque aussi
beaucoup c'est quand la fin du
couvre-feu s'il vous plaît alors la fin
du couvre-feu on a indiqué tout à
l'heure ce sera le 30 juin donc à partir
de ce moment là il y aura plus couvre
feu on pourra sortir on a toute la nuit
sans limite
mais voilà on rappelle les différentes
phases du couvre feu donc 21h à partir
d'aujourd'hui 23 heures à paris le 9
juin et plus couvre-feu finlande et donc
on pourra commencer à admirer les
couchers de soleil même à partie quand
le couvre feu sera à 23 heures parce que
le soleil
oui très bonne question de partir de ce
soir le coup je le souhaite se couchent
peut-être encore avant 21h j'ai une
question concernant les les voyages elsa
qu'est-ce qu'on a le droit de faire
aujourd'hui est ce que le pays s'est un
peu plus ouvert aujourd'hui où ça ne
change pas grand chose concernant les
voyages après ça dépend des politiques
des pays au cas par cas donc en tout cas
pour commencer par la france les
restrictions de 10 km ont été levées il
y avait à peu près deux semaines
donc s'il s'agit de voyager sur le
territoire français vraisemblablement il
n'y a pas de problème à moins que
l'épidémie reprennent dans tel ou tel
département
on a aussi un protocole défini pour les
pays interne de les pays de l'union
européenne finalement à part si au moins
on veut passer d'un pays à l'autre au
sein de l'union européenne
il y a tout un dispositif qui va être
mis en place à partir de mi juin qui
correspond et qui lie à la mise en place
du pass sanitaire européen qui est censé
rendre interopérables tous les pass and
i ter dont on parle en france en
allemagne
en italie pour faire en sorte de pouvoir
scanner aux frontières un qr code qui
prouvera soit qu'on a été vaccinée soit
qu'on a fait un test pcr négatif dans
les 72 heures soit qu'on a le certificat
d'immunité dont on parle est également
tout à l'heure mais il ya quelque chose
dont on s'est rendu compte récemment et
qui est bon à savoir c'est que le qr
code qui figurent actuellement sur les
certificats de vaccination ne sera pas
celui qui sera scanné aux frontières
européennes
à partir du moment où le pass anitea
européen sera mis en place il faudra
télécharger un nouveau qr code sur le
site de l'assurance maladie qui lui
pourra services de servir de preuve de
vaccination de tests pcr négatif ou de
certificats d'humilité et à ce qu on a
une idée de la date de cette entrée en
vigueur du ce est prévu pour mi juin
pour mi juin est la date de l'entrée en
vigueur du pass sanitaire en france ces
avancées le 9 juin s'est légèrement
avant oui très bien merci enfin merci
pierre rousseau qui nous dit merci
d'avoir répondu à mes questions c'est
très cool on est là pour çà elsa et moi
donc n'hésitez pas si vous avez d'autres
questions sur les jauges sur les
protocoles sanitaires sur ceux qui
restent ouverts ou ceux qui restent
fermées ce qu'on a droit de faire ce
qu'on à droite pas pas faire encore
aujourd'hui je voudrais qu'on fasse un
point peut-être sur les les étudiants
sur l'enseignement supérieur et qu'est
ce que ça change pour eux aujourd'hui
quelques genres les étudiants à partir
d'aujourd'hui les salles de cours en
amphithéâtre peuvent accueillir 50 % des
effectifs donc à compter du 19 mai cette
chose s'applique jusqu'à la rentrée de
septembre et a priori les examens
peuvent se tenir en présentiel
donc d'ici là voilà c'est ce qui va
changer
globalement pour faire en sorte que les
étudiants puissent réaliser leur entrée
sans entraves sanitaires il ya déjà eu
des changements pour les plus petites
classes son conseil à partir du 3 mai
les lycées et collèges ont réouvert
aussi en me jugent donc on et voilà sur
un ajustement un petit peu au cas par
cas et au fil du temps pour les
étudiants lycéens et collégiens
on a aussi des informations sur les
conservatoires par exemple pour les
lycéens et collégiens qui y aurait des
cours dans ces établissements la reprise
en présentiel peut se faire à partir
d'aujourd'hui pareil pour les écoles de
danse par exemple
merci merci elsa pour ces précisions on
va retrouver une dernière fois notre
équipe qui est en vadrouille dans paris
dans le 9ème arrondissement
on va on va retrouver maria amelie
bauchet et renan laisse blaise qui sont
devant une nouvelle terrasse une autre
terrasse
ça y est les cafés commence vraiment
remplir ici on commence à voir vraiment
des clients des gens qui viennent
prendre leur petit déjeuner s'arrêter
quelques minutes avant d'aller au
travail pour eux c'est vraiment le début
d'une belle journée qui s'annonce et
tout le monde est très optimiste très
heureux de pouvoir passer un moment avec
des amis avec des collègues avant
d'aller passer une journée au travail
est ici les serveurs les patrons sont
très très heureux de reprendre
voilà donc maintenant dans ces cafés
joie sourire vraiment sont sur tous les
visages
pour pour cette grande journée merci
merci marie amélie et merci à renan
laisse beck qui laisse baisse qui est
filmé qui vous filmer dans les rues de
paris
on va on va terminer sur l'âge par une
dernière question elsa qu'est ce qu'on
aura qu'est-ce qu'on n'a pas le droit de
faire aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui ne
rouvre pas finalement alors ce qu'on n'a
pas le droit de faire aujourd'hui c'est
d'aller en discothèque
donc on disait tout à l'heure ces
établissements n'ont pas d'horizon de
réouverture on n'a pas le droit non plus
de se rendre du moins pas dans ces
prochains jours dans des parcs
d'attraction dans des fêtes foraines
elles ne vont rouvrir qu'à partir du 9
juin on a eu les dates récemment de
réouverture notamment du parc astérix le
9 juin de disneyland paris le 17 juin
il me semble que le puy du fou dont on a
beaucoup parlé ouvre un peu plus tard il
y a également voilà des protocoles au
cas par cas pour les stations thermales
qui n'ouvre pas directement qui vont
être amenés à rouvrir à 100% à partir du
9 juin
en fait elles rouvrent directement mais
avec une jauge de 50% dès aujourd'hui et
on a aussi tout ce qui concerne les
casinos donc à partir d'aujourd'hui il
rouvre mais seuls mais seulement pour
les activités sans contact et à partir
du 9 juin
toutes les activités seront ouvertes
avec une jauge d'accueil de 50 % georges
qui sera également levé à partir du 30
juin
les activités sans contact si je
comprends bien au casino c'est les
machines à sou c'est ça mais pas les
les jeux de cartes en fait voilà c'est
ça les gens autour des tables oui c'est
un terme qui se prête à ces places et
environnement mais en tout cas c'est le
expression qui utilisaient évité sans
contact des casinos donc les machines à
sous
voilà il ya également toute une
politique pour les bowling escape game
salle de jeux un peu plus à la marge il
faut attendre aussi le 9 juin pour la
réouverture est dans un premier temps à
50% des capacités
merci merci elsa merci à vous tous qui
nous avaient suivait sûr sur youtube et
sur lefigaro.fr j'espère qu'on a pu
répondre à toutes vos questions
n'hésitez pas à composer d'autres sur le
prochain live nous avons une
programmation live quotidienne vous êtes
toujours la bienvenue dans le dans le
tchat
merci l âtre gillot je rappelle que vous
êtes journaliste au service économie du
figaro
on vous retrouve donc dans les pages du
figaro ou sur lefigaro.fr pour des
prochains papier de prochains articles
et on vous laisse avec ces images en
direct d'une terrasse bien remplie à
bientôt sur figaro live